You know, I get this a lot when I talk about canning,
and I think it's because we fear what we don't fully understand.
But the good news is that knowledge replaces that fear.
Our grannies and the grannies before them
knew how to preserve their harvest.
They had to preserve their harvest because they were eating regionally
and they were eating seasonally.
Grocery stores were not a thing.
And while grocery stores are a beautiful and wonderful gift,
they are also the cause of so many people being out of touch
of where their food comes from.
Subsequently, the skills of learning to preserve have been lost.
And I do think that certain alphabet agencies do fear mongering
what you can and can't do in canning
because they want you to be reliant on the system that they've created.
Food grown from your own backyard and canned in your own home
is 1,000% safer than anything you can get at a grocery store.
Variants is always your greatest asset in life.
So if you're worried about canning,
come along with me and let me teach you how to can.